[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le 7 8 c'est
votre émission sur TV 78 pour bien
démarrer la soirée dans les Yvelines
avec de l'actualité des Infopratique et
des idées de sortie au programme on
regarde tout de suite le sommaire de ce
9 janvier
tout au long du mois de janvier période
traditionnelle des vœux TV 78 reçoit les
maires de 50 ans en Yvelines pour parler
des grands projets de l'année 2023 dans
leur ville ce soir focus sur la verrière
et novation du quartier et du bois de
l'étang garbeken départ du Paris-Nice à
quoi faut-il s'attendre le maire de la
commune Nicolas Dainville et notre
invité
démos revient dans les Yvelines ce
projet porté par la Cité de la Musique
Philharmonie de Paris éduque les 8 12
ans à la pratique de la musique en
orchestre ces jeunes habitent dans des
quartiers politiques de la ville où en
zone rurale samedi une centaine
d'enfants s'est vu un sirène un
instrument de musique au théâtre de 50
ans en Yvelines
et puis le sport avec du rugby plaisir à
réaliser un très bon début de
championnat une très bonne première
partie de saison en Fédérale 2 alors que
le club actuel deuxième du championnat
retourne sur le terrain ce dimanche
après la pause des Fêtes peut-on parler
officiellement d'objectif monté nous en
profiterons également pour présenter la
section féminine qui compte de plus en
plus de licenciés on parlera de ce sujet
rugby avec nos deux invités qui sont en
plateau avec nous Sébastien roncali et
Hugo thaïlandais thaïlandais bonsoir
donc manager de la catégorie senior au
plaisir Rugby Club et ailier dans cette
équipe alors je le disais reprise des
matchs la phase retour alors qu'il y
avait déjà démarré juste avant les fêtes
mais là c'est la suite de la phase
retour à partir de dimanche avec la
réception de Ris-Orangis la préparation
zéro bien coach ouais très bien une
belle reprise là on a fait une bonne
semaine la semaine dernière et là ça
s'annonce très bien aussi cette semaine
donc ça se prépare petit à petit ça se
passe très très bien et du coup est-ce
que vous avez été raisonnable on s'est
fait de fin d'année un petit peu il faut
dans l'ancien important de bien attaquer
la saison et puis on a un premier match
qui est capital donc c'est important
d'être d'être prêt et on parlera tout à
l'heure cette rencontre face à
Ris-Orangis c'est aussi des objectifs ce
qu'on pourra parler de monter au début
de la saison voilà vous préfériez vous
vous avez préféré botter en touche on va
voir si les objectifs ont changé en
cette moitié de saison sera dans la page
sport avec vous nickel elle me Doro
bonsoir exactement
si oui ou non il faut parler de monter
apparemment pour l'instant c'est c'est
encore un peu tabou mais on va on va
peut-être y répondre en quelques
instants et sinon au niveau du sport
résultat sportifs ce weekend exactement
il y aura la victoire de Poissy en
National 2 qui s'est amusé ce week-end à
domicile face à Chartres le score 5 buts
il y a également trap qui a joué ce
week-end et trap qui a perdu face à
saint-charge Charenton Saint-Maurice
dans un instant également les
informations du jour avec vous Mélanie
Boquet bonsoir et du coup aujourd'hui en
deux mots c'est quoi l'actualité Yves
viennoise du jour déjà en quelques mots
une belle année 2022 pour la
fréquentation du Château de Rambouillet
un petit retour sur le ces donc ce sera
dans un instant dans le 7 8 à suivre
aussi deux invités qui viendront nous
présenter le prochain concert des
solistes de la ville lieu c'est ce
vendredi à Trappes mais avant tout cela
place à vos prévisions météo de demain
[Musique]
c'est une journée morose et demain ce
sera également le cas de la grisaille et
de la pluie au programme de la journée
de mardi le matin il fera à 6 degrés
dans la moitié nord du département 5
degrés du côté de Rambouillet et de la
pluie également dans l'après-midi côté
température compter 9 degrés à Houdan et
Mantes-la-Jolie 8 degrés à Versailles et
Rambouillet ce mardi 10 janvier nous
fêterons les Guillaumes
et on va déjà passer dans cette émission
à notre partie sport alors ce sera dans
un instant mais avant cela mais avant
cela j'en parlais il y a un instant
c'est donc les informations du jour avec
vous Mélanie poquet on commence par une
bonne nouvelle du côté de Rambouillet
une belle fréquentation une progression
de 40 % par rapport à 2019 c'est la
fréquentation donc pour l'année 2022 au
château le monument national a accueilli
plus de 100 de 65 000 visiteurs au sein
même de sa structure ou lors des
événements comme le spectacle immersif
secret défense c'est des visiteurs à
plus de 70% français et franciliens pour
la plupart
on traverse la mer l'Atlantique 2000
exposants dont 170 représentants de la
French tech et parmi eux des entreprises
50 chinoises le CIS de Las Vegas c'est
clôturé ce dimanche 8 janvier avec des
technologies innovations toujours plus
surprenante il y avait trois sociétés
yvelinoises buffet crampons
Mantes-la-Jolie qui développe une
solution pour transformer une clarinette
en l'instrument numérique chocolate chip
cookies company société implantée aux
Clayes-sous-Bois qui propose une console
audio et interactive et sensorielle et
toujours ok sous bois
voilà c'est la société
et cette société elle fabrique des
outils de charges et de diagnostic de
batterie de véhicules électriques alors
on va remonter un petit peu dans le
temps en 2021 la ville de Poissy mettait
en place une caution pour éviter les
débordements lors des célébrations de
mariage retour en 2023 c'est un système
qui va avoir le jour aussi du côté de la
ville de Montigny-le-Bretonneux alors
c'est pas encore acté mais la discussion
est ouverte puisque lors de son conseil
local de prévention de la délinquance la
commune a indiqué souhaité actualiser sa
charte autour des mariages la raison
deux ou trois célébrations qui ont
dérapé en 2022 des cortèges sujets
perturbants avec des parades brillantes
et des tirs de mortiers et donc ça c'est
tacté le marché de Voisins-le-Bretonneux
va s'agrandir il cherche des commerçants
des producteurs des artisans ils veulent
diversifier bon marché alors pour les
intéresser il y a une adresse mail à
envoyer pour votre candidature votre
point
courrier@78.fr le marché se tient tous
les samedis matins de 8h à 13h sur le
parking de la poste depuis le 5 novembre
dernier et puis si vous êtes comme moi
très inquiet quand vous avez plus de
batterie sur votre téléphone que vous
avez le petit 5 % qui s'affiche à
Rosny-sur-Seine il y a une solution qui
a été toute trouvée c'est possible de le
recharger maintenant en plein
centre-ville la commune a installé fin
novembre dernier des bancs connectés ils
sont au nombre de trois ils fonctionnent
à l'énergie solaire vous pouvez même y
brancher votre vélo électrique voilà
cette fois faut juste pas oublier votre
chargeur quoi merci Mélanie pour pour
toutes ces informations et si vous aussi
près de chez vous vous êtes témoin d'une
information d'un fait qui vous fait
réagir dans les Yvelines n'hésitez pas à
le partager à le dire sur les réseaux
sociaux en utilisant le hashtag 7 8 news
je voulais anticiper Michael parce que
je suis un passionné de sport il y avait
d'abord notamment les informations du
jour mais on va faire cette partie sport
un peu plus en avance par rapport à
d'habitude dans cette émission et je le
disais tout à l'heure on parle de rugby
essentiellement aujourd'hui oui sur ce
plateau deux piliers du club de rugby de
plaisir pour nous parler des bonnes
prestations de l'équipe senior le
manager général Sébastien rocally et
l'ailier Hugo Taillandier bonsoir
messieurs rebonsoir messieurs alors
plaisir est actuellement deuxième du
championnat de fédéral 2 est-ce que vous
attendiez un tel début de saison
Sébastien
on espérait en tout cas dans la
continuité du travail effectué sur les
cinq dernières années en Fédérale 2 et
notamment l'année dernière où on loupe
la qualification de deux points sur un
match en retard qu'on n'a pas pu jouer
donc voilà on était très frustré malgré
les bons résultats et un bon
enchaînement de victoire notamment sur
une grosse équipe de Nantes où là
c'était vraiment un très très bel
exploit à la maison on espérait cette
année effectivement être dans les 6 et
effectivement on se retrouve deuxième
après un beau parcours sur les matchs
aller donc aujourd'hui oui on espère
confirmer sur les matchs retours Hugo
vous êtes d'accord avec votre coach
toujours
ça se passe pas comme ça je vous assure
oui mais non on est bien évidemment très
content d'être deuxième au classement
maintenant c'est ça continue par le
travail et par le sérieux de de chacun
mais on est sur sur une bonne voie et on
a la chance d'avoir un collectif qui qui
a aussi l'envie de bien faire et de
continuer cette belle aventure il y a eu
trois défaites tout de même sur cette
première partie de saison est-ce que
elle vous reste en travers de la gorge
ou justement comme la première partie de
saison est réussie elles sont un peu
oubliées c'est des fêtes Sébastien sont
très frustrantes également parce que
c'est des défaites on en a deux petits
points une de ces points de 5 points de
8 points donc c'est trois matchs qu'on
aurait pu accrocher
malgré tout ça reste très positif parce
qu'il y a qu'un match je comprends pas
de points c'est au Havre
partir de 8 points mais c'est vrai que
sur le contenu
on pouvait espérer mieux laquelle vous
énerve le plus peut-être Courbevoie à la
maison
et est-ce que votre équipe vous surprend
ou pas Sébastien roncalier est-ce que
vous sentiez que il y avait cette
possibilité d'aller chercher peut-être
une montée peut-être en fin de saison
non je suis pas surpris mais c'est vrai
que il confirme quoi encore une fois
d'aller en année il confirme là cette
année ils sont arrivés on a eu un nombre
de 50 60 joueurs qui sont arrivés
mi-août en forme c'est des choses qui
étaient pas forcément arrivées dans les
années passées Parce que le rugby
amateur c'est pas toujours simple de de
faire les choses dans le bon sens à ce
niveau là mais là les mecs sont arrivés
très très en forme ce qui explique aussi
certainement ce bon début et comment
vous expliquer justement ce changement
de mentalité peut-être qui est encore
plus professionnel si je peux dire au
sein de Rugby Club de c'est je pense que
c'est l'envie de bien faire et puis en
fait on a aussi un staff qui est qui
s'entend bien et sans le ressent aussi
en tant que en tant que joueur
et je pense que c'est important aussi
d'avoir la confiance et être dans
l'échange et en fait tous les choses se
font très naturellement parce que quand
on a de la confiance quand on peut
dialoguer et quand on peut discuter de
plein de choses que ça soit sur le
terrain ou en dehors de terrain
malheureusement ça se ressent et c'est
important pour pour ce qui se passe le
dimanche tout simplement le groupe
Vibien le groupe vit très très bien il y
a un bon mélange entre les entre les
anciens les nouveaux exactement ça c'est
c'est aussi ce qu'on en parlait avec
Sébastien c'est il y a un mélange qui se
fait et puis il y a des générations qui
arrivent et tout le monde est accepté et
ça c'est aussi hyper important c'est ça
aussi qui fait la force de votre groupe
aujourd'hui
de l'extérieur et qui ont été totalement
dans l'esprit du club et qui sont
parfaitement intégrés et qui permettent
aujourd'hui d'avoir comme disait Hugo un
groupe homogène de garçon qui sont
tournés vers le même objectif et on a
au-delà des résultats de l'équipe
première on a aussi une équipe B qui
tourne très très bien et c'est pour ça
qu'on ait une concurrence saine et voilà
un très bel état d'esprit dans tout tout
va dans le bon sens et sur quoi vous
devez travailler du coup coach
on a toujours des tas de choses à
travailler dans notre sport on a
tellement de domaines de travail et
encore une fois nous dans le sport
amateurs
effectivement et justement par rapport à
ce travail là vidéo nous on n'est pas
sur des possibilités de voir nos gars
tous les jours donc voilà c'est un
travail
constant permanent et voilà on arrive à
trouver des petits moments où on peut
échanger avec les joueurs sur ce sujet
ouais en début de saison on était venu
vous voir à l'occasion du derby de cette
fédéral de face à Versailles il y avait
une belle victoire à l'époque voilà vous
nous disiez que l'objectif c'était
d'atteindre au moins les phases finales
pour pour cette saison est-ce qu'on peut
parler d'objectif monté ou l'objectif
reste inchangé c'est déjà de valider
votre place dans ces phases finales non
en premier lieu ouais c'est
effectivement validé notre place dans
les phases finales puisqu'on fait des R2
on l'a jamais connu donc ça c'est le
premier gros objectif mais effectivement
bah là j'ai envie de vous dire l'appétit
vient en mangeant donc
on en parle forcément on prépare
l'avenir parce que si ça doit arriver il
faut être prêt pour pour cet événement
c'est la motivation pour les joueurs
cette possibilité
bien sûr c'est une grosse motivation
quand on parlait pas de monter il y a
deux trois ans et puis on se rend compte
que on est quand même maintenant un
statut où on est attendu quand on vient
se quand on vient un peu se frotter un
peu à plaisir à domicile bah c'est
jamais simple on entend de plus en plus
ouais plaisir ça fait des ça fait des
bons résultats et oui ce serait ce
serait magnifique même au-delà de ça
sportivement pour un groupe c'est c'est
quelque chose de beau et puis si on peut
réussir pourquoi pas aller chercher
cette fédérale une ce serait quand même
quelque chose de très beau et puis
beaucoup de souvenirs aussi donc ouais
étape par étape ou euh clairement
l'afficher étape par étape voilà là il y
en a une reprise qui va être importante
capitale enfin c'est une belle équipe de
Ris-Orangis qui nous a battu au match
aller donc on sait que ça va pas être
simple vous parliez de nos amis de
Versailles qui nous attendent dans la
continuité le week-end d'après la
prochaine question justement le derby
contre Versailles qui est sixième du
classement de fédéral 2 donc ça sera un
gros match ah oui oui qu'on sera on sera
bien reçu et que ça sera forcément un
gros match en plus certes ils ont pris
quelques points chez nous à la maison
mais depuis ils font des bons résultats
on voit qu'ils travaillent bien on voit
que ça progresse aussi chez eux voilà
ils ont découvert cette année le niveau
mais bon je pense qu'ils seront vraiment
prêts là je sais qu'ils étaient en stage
le week-end dernier donc voilà oui bien
sûr bien sûr bah toujours pareil par le
biais de la vidéo même à notre niveau
c'est de plus en plus fréquent que les
équipes se filment et travaillent avec
donc effectivement on arrive toujours à
avoir des images pour vous demander pour
la monter si je comprends bien
ce sera la même réponse et un mot très
rapide sur le match de ce dimanche on en
a parlé face à Ris-Orangis réception de
Ris-Orangis qui est sixième au
classement si je dis pas de bêtises
un mot sur sur ce match tout est tout
est prêt pour ce match ça se passe en 5e
5e
non après on sait que ça va être
difficile voilà c'est une équipe aussi
qui travaille bien ils sont montés en
même temps que nous il y a 5 ans de ma
buse il y a 6 ans donc on est un peu sur
le même profil de club et de travail
voilà ils ont des ambitions aussi voilà
encore une fois je vous dis ce match là
on sait que voilà c'est le le tournant
pour pouvoir prétendre après justement à
une évolution ou pas
c'est tout le mal que l'on peut vous
souhaiter pour pour cette fin de saison
on va parler Michael également de rugby
féminin alors toujours un plaisir c'est
une entente qui fait de plus en plus
parler edels son nom c'est les Panthères
cette association a été créée il y a un
peu moins de deux entre le plaisir Rugby
Club et Vélizy-Villacoublay justement
vous nous présentez cette équipe nickel
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
de la joie sur les visages de ces rugby
woman ce dimanche 8 janvier les
Panthères viennent de remporter leur
deuxième victoire de la saison face à
Courbevoie en régionale une belle
performance pour cette entente ivinoise
entreprise et Vélizy-Villacoublay en
rugby à 10 on concrétise du travail
qu'on fait depuis maintenant un an et
demi quoi parce que c'est depuis l'année
dernière la saison dernière qu'on a
cette entente avec Vélizy et là on est
récompensé de tous les efforts qu'on
fait à chaque entraînement dans le club
de plaisir on travaille depuis une
dizaine d'années sur la section féminine
ici le rugby féminin connaît un vrai
boom avec une soixantaine de licenciés
trois fois plus en trois ans aujourd'hui
on a le bonheur d'avoir des fils dans
toutes les catégories des moins de 8 des
moins de 10 des moins de 12 des moins de
15 on est le seul club à yvelinois avoir
une équipe complète en moins de 15 donc
les millimètres et nos canettes depuis 3
ans performent énormément sur tout le
résultat à terme la section féminine a
pour objectif d'aller vers le haut
niveau dans les trois quatre prochaines
années mais le principal est de créer
avant tout une identité de club c'est ça
notre force c'est qu'on a créé une
famille on fait plein de choses ensemble
on essaie de se voir après
l'entraînement de se voir les week-ends
qui a fait pas mal d'années sur circuit
international sur le Seven
et quand un publié qui est le second
prof de sport qui est licencié chez nous
et qui joue sur notre équipe trois
seniors voilà sont deux personnes qui
sont vraiment engagées sur le projet qui
font un travail formidable sur la
section et qui aliment le club bien sûr
en permanence tous les ans et un gros
développement et on espère encore qu'on
va avoir de plus gros résultats sur ce
sujet
la Coupe du Monde féminine a joué
peut-être aussi sur le nombre de
licenciés cette année on pense aussi à
Émilie Boulard qui est très fier
des Yvelines qui a brillé pendant cette
Coupe du Monde Féminine est-ce que ça
aide justement à attirer de nouveaux
licencier bien sûr les bons résultats
des équipes de France font toujours
forcément du bien à notre sport et
notamment les féminines qui qui ont
vraiment des très bons résultats que ce
soit sur le Seven ou le ou le 15 leur
performances nous aide bien sûr à
attirer les jeunes filles oui Hugo je
crois que vous venez souvent les
supporter
on a pas match bien évidemment on va
supporter les féminines mais au-delà de
ça oui pour avoir fait plusieurs
plusieurs matchs enfin en allant les
regarder c'est un groupe qui vit bien
aussi il y a pas de il y a pas de
problème là-dessus et puis nous on
accepte aussi en seniors masculin on
accepte aussi les féminines et puis
c'est super sympa parce qu'on fait plein
de découvertes aussi c'est un esprit
club c'est un esprit club c'est ça ouais
et puis on retrouve pas il y a pas ce
Vélizy plaisir c'est vraiment une grosse
famille et c'est vraiment sympathique et
c'est quoi l'objectif du coup dans les
prochaines années ce que le haut niveau
ça peut être jouable pour cette section
alors là pour le coup de notre ambition
dès le début parce que
même si ça se développe beaucoup on sait
qu'on a une place à aller chercher quoi
parce qu'on est et bien structuré et
donc si on continue à travailler alors
déjà par étape là aujourd'hui nos filles
elles jouent à 10
déjà évoluer au rugby à 15 donc encore
c'est au fait un peu et puis après oui
après ça peut ça peut vite s'ouvrir même
merci à vous deux d'être passé Sébastien
et Hugo et votre prochain match pour
l'équipe fanion de ce Rugby Club de
plaisir je le rappelle ce sera ce
dimanche 15 janvier 15 janvier face à
Ris-Orangis à domicile juste on n'oublie
pas le 22 janvier aussi controver le
dernier le retour le retour de ce derby
remporté à l'aller c'était un plaisir
justement le plaisir Rugby Club juste
avant de passer aux autres résultats
sportifs du week-end accueillir notre
nouvelle invité Nicolas Dainville
bonsoir bonsoir mère de la verrière avec
vous dans quelques instants on va pas on
va parler des grands projets de 2023 à
La Verrière puisque janvier c'est aussi
une période traditionnelle de vœux vous
allez faire les vôtres vendredi je pense
vendredi 13 c'est ça normalement
important les jeux pour une commune ça
permet de faire preuve de pédagogie ça
permet de rencontrer les habitants ça
permet aussi d'avoir un moment de
convivialité autour d'un petit peu de
l'amitié non non c'est un moment
essentiel qu'on a pas pu vivre pour moi
en tout cas en tant que mère depuis mon
élection avec le confinement et le covid
donc là c'est un moment d'autant plus
attendu on parle de ça dans un instant
et Nicolas
dans quelques instants parce que la
ville va accueillir le Paris Nice la
première étape du Paris ce sera le 5
mars prochain ce sera effectivement l'un
des grands rendez-vous 2023 pour pour la
commune de La Verrière on va en parler
dans un instant mais on va continuer de
parler des autres sports aussi Michael
avec les résultats sportifs du week-end
et on jouait notamment sur les terrains
de football dans le championnat de
National 2 Poissy c'est amusé ce
week-end à domicile les pissacées se
sont imposés 5 1 face à Chartres devant
leur supporter les buteurs piece double
buteur Amadou Konaté Yves DJ Yannick
mamilon au classement la 3e place avec
21 points grands jeux en 14 journées
disputées après les fêtes on reprenait
les matchs sur les parquets de basket
dans le championnat de National 3 trap a
perdu ce samedi soir sur le parquet de
Saint-Charles Charenton Saint-Maurice le
score 81 à 75 une défaite qui fait mal
au trappiste il redescende à la 6e place
du championnat ils ont actuellement 21
points avec 5 défaites depuis le début
du championnat Massy est premier du
championnat à 3 du basket féminin
également programme dans le championnat
de National de les féminines de
l'Entente Le Chesnay Versailles se sont
inclinés de justesse sur le score de 65
à 60 face à Mondeville basket une des
fêtes compliquée sur le plan comptable
pour les Yvelines Oise à sont
actuellement la sixième place du
championnat loin du leader
déplacement s'inclinant à domicile face
à Bully-les-Mines le résumé du match
viser une victoire pour bien commencer
l'année c'était le souhait de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux qui recevait
builly-les-mines à l'occasion de la
dixième journée de Nationale 2 après une
première période équilibrée entre les
deux équipes pour les contacts sont
présents se sont finalement les
illimontaines qui rentrent au vestiaires
avec un but d'avance le score à la poste
14 à 13 sur la première période on était
plutôt bien on était très engagés il y
avait une très bonne défense il y avait
une bonne attaque il y a des petites
erreurs notamment sur les changements de
timing qu'on fait pas forcément sur les
prises intervalles qu'on a pas forcément
dans les dans le dans les bons espaces
sur des lâchés de balles qui sont pas
aussi précises que ce qui faudrait pour
pouvoir avoir une continuité dans le jeu
mais on arrive à peu près à s'en sortir
en général sur les premières mi-temps au
retour des vestiaires la dynamique n'est
pas bonne pour Montigny-le-Bretonneux au
complexe sportif Pierre de Coubertin et
joueuse locale se font dépasser au
tableau d'affichage elle ne reviendront
pas malgré de bonnes séquences les
Yvelinois s'inclinent 27 à 25 on perd
encore une fois à domicile mais c'est
encore une fois sur la deuxième mi-temps
sur nos erreurs on a trois fois plus de
pertes de balle en deuxième mi-temps
qu'en première comme les matchs qu'on
perd en général voilà et puis c'est vrai
que depuis un certain temps on avait la
meilleure attaque depuis un certain
temps on n'arrive pas à dépasser la
barre des 26 buts forcément on est un
peu déçu puisque on voulait gagner ce
premier match avec cette nouvelle année
mais je pense que on va pouvoir se
relever assez rapidement de ça on va
travailler à l'entraînement on prend
chaque match comme il vient celui-là on
s'est raté mais on va revenir vite dès
la semaine prochaine justement pour pour
juste nous rebooster déjà la semaine
prochaine le 14 janvier les
joueusilles-vinois se déplaceront sur le
terrain de Corbie à l'occasion de la 11e
journée une rencontre où les ini
Montaigne seront favorites
Montigny-le-Bretonneux occupe
actuellement la quatrième place du
classement et son futur adversaire la
dixième
et merci Michael pour toutes ces
précisions au programme notamment cette
semaine niveau sport une un nouveau
rendez-vous de si on parlait sport
spécial Jeux olympiques
de 2024 qui arrivent bientôt c'est
bientôt et on parlera de golf on ira du
côté du golf national de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines qui va
accueillir du coup les épreuves de golf
on parle on aura comme invité à Pascal
grisou le président de la Fédération
Française de Golf on aura également
Philippe pilateau qui est directeur du
Golf National de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines alors le
courtier qui s'occupe des Jeux
Olympiques au niveau de l'agglomération
de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines et on aura
également une sportive avec Alexandra
Bonetti qui est une joueuse
professionnelle de golf merci Michael et
donc c'est au rendez-vous c'est
retrouver comme rendez-vous cette
semaine tout de suite la suite du 7 8
et je le disais tout à l'heure janvier
c'est la période traditionnelle pour
présenter ses vœux plusieurs communes
d'ailleurs de 50 ans en Yvelines des
Yvelines mais aussi de toute la France
organise leur cérémonie pour souhaiter
une bonne année alors habitons et tout
au long du mois de janvier télé 78
reçoit les maires des communes de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines pour parler
des grands projets de 2023 dans leur
ville Nicolas Dainville voilà vous avez
switché de place vous êtes passé de
l'autre côté vous inaugurez ce tour
d'horizon des mers de Saint-Quentin en
Yvelines je le rappelle Edil de la
commune de La Verrière vous êtes
également vice-président de
l'agglomération de 50 ans en Yvelines et
du département des Yvelines alors en ce
début d'année le mot aussi qui revient
dans toutes les bouches c'est celui de
la sobriété énergétique qu'est-ce qui a
été fait dans la ville de La Verrière
qu'est-ce qui a été fait déjà en 2022 et
qu'est-ce que vous prévoyez de faire
justement en 2023 pour aller vers plus
d'économies ben écoutez déjà un chiffre
c'est vrai que la facture de gaz pour la
ville de La Verrière c'est multiplié par
5 donc c'est des coûts qui explosent qui
nous aujourd'hui effectivement à des
vrais efforts on a baissé la température
dans nos équipements publics on s'est
mis sur les recommandations de de l'État
on a également entreprises un
remplacement de notre éclairage avec
plus de LED on a malheureusement à
contrecœur
vraiment drastiquement diminué nos
illuminations de Noël on a transformé
notre concours d'illumination au
concours de décoration on a lancé des
audits énergétiques pour essayer de de
mieux consommer
et puis on investit sur l'avenir
notamment avec les quartiers qu'on va
essayer de réhabiliter de manière
ambitieuse pour qu'il y ait des
meilleurs isolations des meilleurs
consommations pour que ça soit aux
normes environnementales les plus
modernes les plus innovantes puisque
justement dans la vidéo de présentation
de vos vœux vous en avez fait une en
avant première parce que veut officiels
ce sera ce vendredi au scarabée vous
avez parlé des habitants notamment du
bois de l'étang qui était durement
touchés par la hausse des charges
comment la ville peut les accompagner en
allant vers plus de rénovation
énergétique en les accompagnant sur sur
ce sujet exactement ça a été assez
terrible pour pour les habitants du bois
de l’étang qui ont vu leur facture
parfois multipliées par trois leur
charge qui ont donc brutalement et
massivement augmenté la ville a
accompagné les familles les plus
fragilisées avec notre CCAS pour les
accompagner à mobiliser les aides
auxquelles ils ont le droit pour les
aider pour vraiment ceux qui étaient les
plus en précarité mais effectivement sur
le long terme il faut vraiment
réhabiliter les logements pour consommer
mieux consommer moins et donc c'est
toute l'ambition de notre projet avec
l'enru l'Agence nationale de rénovation
urbaine c'est près de 80 millions
d'euros qui vont être investis pour le
quartier de réalisation c'est sans
précédent dans ces 80 millions il y a la
nouvelle école il y a la nouvelle maison
de quartier il y a les voiries si on
parle de rénovation de démolition de
logement mais aussi de mise en place de
nouveaux services également exactement
la démolition de logement c'est 212
logements démoli et plus de 400
puissamment réhabilités sur les
installations sur les sanitaires sur les
canalisations sur l'isolation thermique
sur le système de chauffage qui va
permettre justement de consommer mieux
sur l'aspect extérieur également pour
changer l'image de quartier pour
améliorer l'attractivité il y aura même
une formule avec des couronnes sur les
toitures pour avoir une vision du
quartier au loin qui soit très moderne
l'idée c'est pas de se dire c'est tours
ont été réhabilités c'est qu'on ait
l'impression que ce sont des nouvelles
tours modernes casser aussi le côté
grand ensemble pour résidentialiser
améliorer le stationnement bref c'est un
quartier pour qui va changer pour
améliorer la qualité de vie est-ce que
les travaux ont déjà démarré ce que ça
va être le cas cette année alors là le
diagnostic va progressivement prendre
fin les travaux vont commencer dans
l'année qui vient c'est des travaux qui
s'étale sur plusieurs années puisque les
travaux n'ont par logement sont quand
même assez puissants
on parle à peu près de 65000 euros par
logement c'est le ratio donc c'est ratio
important
sans précédent comme je le disais donc
c'est effectivement un des projets
essentiels au projet du siècle comme
jamais à le dire pour la verrière qui va
rentrer dans une phase très concrète là
dans quelques mois pour le quartier
d'Orly parc aussi les choses bougent en
2023 bah exactement on a terminé nos
aménagements extérieurs dont on est
assez fier et que l'équipe on voulait un
effet waouh pour vraiment avoir le
meilleur en termes d'équipement avec des
aires de jeux le boulot de Rome le
street workout mis à la fois sur le
sport et sur des espaces de convivialité
on a des tables de jeu d'échec par
exemple voilà maintenant il y a toute la
partie réhabilitation des logements qui
se précisent avec le bailleur pour
essayer aussi de d'améliorer certaines
difficultés notamment en termes
d'humidité qui se pose encore dans
beaucoup de logements mais je dirais que
sur Orly park on a quand même un nouveau
souffle une nouvelle dynamique qui a pu
s'enclencher on en parlait aussi sur ce
plateau il y a quelques semaines c'est
aussi tout le quartier autour de la qui
va être en mutation et les travaux
d'aménagement ça ça déjà démarré qui
sont en cours sur le Polgar ça se
poursuit aussi dans les années à venir
avec le projet de futurs écoquartiers
garbecane alors des sataniques il y a un
nouveau parking qui est en cours de
construction notamment dans cette cet
espace gare ce polyguard exactement le
nouveau parking va ouvrir la dans
quelques semaines c'est 914 places pour
être précis avec une autoconsommation
donc des panneaux photovoltaïques qui
vont permettre à ce parking de
fonctionner de manière autonome et ça va
surtout permettre de dégager de
l'emprise au sol pour avoir un grand
parvis piéton et végétalisé qui va
améliorer
l'accessibilité pour les piétons avec
une rampe d'accès aussi pour les
personnes mobilité réduite qui va être
vraiment améliorée c'est un gros dossier
dont la ville ne maîtrise pas l'ensemble
des tenants et des aboutissants c'est
nos partenaires qui investissent
puissamment je pense à Saint-Quentin je
pense au département il y a la région
mais ça va vraiment permettre d'avoir un
vrai quartier de ce qui manquait
aujourd'hui et notamment sur la partie
nord avec ce fameux parvis et cette
offre de commerce qui devrait également
être amélioré alors dès cette année
aussi ça me fait partie des gros projets
il y a un poste de police municipale qui
est mise en place exactement il est déjà
ouvert il est déjà inauguré c'était
effectivement une de des ambitions de
notre de notre équipe d'avoir une police
municipale renforcée donc on a trois
agents ils ont des vélos ils ont
également des armes des armes non
létales mais des teasers pour ne pas les
citer qui vont permettre voilà de de
mener des opérations notamment de
sécurité routière en toute sécurité et
ils sont accompagnés d'une équipe de
médiateurs c'était aussi une des grandes
ambitions d'en parler sur ce plateau
pendant la campagne électorale c'est
vrai que l'équipe précédente n'avait pas
réussi à avoir les les financements de
l'État pour avoir les deux médiateurs
qui auraient pourtant eu le droit et là
on a maintenant une équipe de cinq
médiateurs donc 4 sont financés par
l'État pour la tranquillité public pour
arpenter nos rues parler avec nos jeunes
des amorcer des conflits et veiller à la
tranquillité dans la rue alors je le
cite parce que vous en parlez également
dans cette vidéo qui a retrouvé un sur
le site de La Verrière ou par le site du
déploiement des tablettes qui va se
poursuivre avec des écoliers de
primaires qui sont concernés des projets
culturels également qui sont menés avec
la Philharmonie de Paris avec le Centre
de Musique Baroque de Versailles on
parle de démo on aura un reportage à
voir dans un instant et également donc
le projet ville baroque qui est mené
mais le rendez-vous dont on parlait il y
a un instant nickel qui est toujours
avec nous en plateau rendez-vous à ne
pas manquer c'est ce Paris-Nice cette
81e édition du Paris-Nice la Course au
Soleil s'élancera le 5 mars depuis la
verrière c'est ça le 5 mars depuis la
verrière alors si j'ai bien compris le
village départ sera au niveau du du parc
Philippe Cousteau c'est bien ça si je me
suis pas trompé le déplace devant la
mairie devant la mairie c'est un
événement mais le bilan le village
effectivement sera au parc Philipp du
Cousteau c'est un événement historique
pour une une petite commune comme la
nôtre c'est près de 8 millions de
téléspectateurs qui ont les yeux rivés
sur la verrière donc un coup de
projecteur hors norme c'est une vraie
fierté parce que ça va renforcer le
sentiment d'appartenance à la ville ça
permet de rayonner de parler de
patrimoine trop souvent méconnu je pense
notamment de pochettes au jardin dessiné
par Le Nôtre toute l'histoire de ce
château incroyable avec le compte de la
Valette qui était l'aide de quand de
Bonaparte donc ça va vraiment être un
événement je dirais sans précédent
historique hors norme et on est associé
avec le Mesnil-Saint-Denis puisque donc
les coureurs s'élancent de la mairie
vont ensuite passer devant la gare
remonter sur la venue de Montfort
parcourir le Mesnil les 17 tournants la
vallée de Chevreuse repasser une seconde
fois dans la verrière et terminer sur la
grande avenue du Général Leclerc au
niveau de la rue Henriette sur la
commune du Mesnil-Saint-Denis pour un
sprint pour un sprint c'est vrai qu'il y
aura les meilleurs coureurs de la de la
planète tu auras le vainqueur du Tour de
France donc pour ceux qui le vélo qui
aime je dirais ces événements
planétaires c'est un engouement
populaire assez extraordinaire et on
aurait effectivement aussi une occasion
d'avoir un événement de convivialité
avec nos associations donc sur ce parc
Philippe Cousteau les associations de
nos deux communes Ménil Saint-Denis la
verrière qui sont sollicités vous savez
à peu près combien il y aura de
personnes de visiteurs sur la verrière
pendant le Paris-Nice alors une chose
est sûre ça sera un grand bazar en
termes de circulation mais on va
travailler avec le département pour tout
ce qui est barriérage avec un Boris pour
organisation pour la partie parcours
également avec Saint-Quentin qui va nous
aider sur le sur les parkings le
stationnement j'ai pas de chiffres
précis à vous communiquer c'est son
humilié mais plusieurs milliers de
personnes voilà moi j'étais allé à
Mantes-la-Ville pour le départ de
l'année dernière et c'est vrai que
c'était plusieurs milliers de personnes
et avec un public très familial très
passionné qui vient de loin et et avec
un sport qui n'a pas encore repris la
mauvaise tournure du sport business
comme dans le football c'est à dire
qu'il y a des échanges possibles avec
les joueurs ils les coureurs avec les
équipes et c'est ça qui est assez
extraordinaire dans le vélo très
rapidement un rassemblement City
rassemble justement cette libérations
les passionnés celui de des Mustang il
avait été annulé à cause de la crise
carburant il y aura bien lieu au
printemps finalement il a été déplacé au
mois de juin au mois de juin c'est un
événement qui permet la vie de rayonner
sur une thématique atypique on veut être
la capitale francilienne de la Mustang
c'est un événement de passionné c'est
pas du tout un des voitures bling bling
comme d'autres marques qu'on ne citera
pas c'est au contraire des voitures qui
symbolisent la liberté qui sont
mythiques avec des passionnés qui ont
envie de partager cette passion et qui
permettent de récolter de l'argent pour
les associations c'est les restos du
cœur la dernière fois il y aura d'autres
associations qui seront sélectionnées
pour ce weekend de juin ou le
l'événement sera organisé et pour
terminer cet entretien l'interview
express
[Musique]
le principe Nicolas David je vais vous
poser cinq questions à nous poserons les
mêmes à tous les maires qui viendront
sur notre plateau en janvier une
exigence des réponses courtes certaines
nécessitent un oui ou un nom un pour ou
contre donc ça c'est très facile ou les
autres pour celles qui demandent un peu
plus explications je vais vous demander
de répondre en 20 secondes maximum alors
la première question est-ce qu'en 2023
vous augmenterez les impôts locaux dans
votre commune réponse non c'est pas du
tout prévu même si je dois quand même
souligner une grande incertitude
budgétaire puisque la ville de La
Verrière je le rappelle souvent c'est
72% de logements sociaux donc on est une
ville dépendante de tous nos partenaires
et les dotations de l'État et de nos
partenaires ont tendance plutôt à fondre
comme neige au soleil donc pas
d'augmentation d'impôts prévus mais une
grande rigueur sur les services sur le
le fonctionnement mais c'est la
certitude pour pour les autres années en
tout cas pour cette année aucune
augmentation d'un pot de prévu alors
côté circulation certaines communes ont
fait le de passer de limiter leur
vitesse dans la commune à 30 km/h ce que
vous êtes pour ou contre une telle
mesure je trouve ça très intéressant
pour la commune de La Verrière la
décision n'est pas prise on a des
réflexions qui sont menées sur le
stationnement avec des zones bleues
notamment pour certains parkings sur la
circulation notamment sur les pistes
cyclables ou avec l'agglo il faut qu'on
se positionne très vite pour voir les
rues qui vont pouvoir accueillir des
pistes
pour l'instant pas de décision prise sur
les 30 km/h mais en tout cas une
incitation avec la police municipale
vraiment réduire drastiquement la
vitesse sur nos routes pour ou contre
l'obligation du bio dans les cantines
pour une incitation ça c'est dans le cas
de nos clients pas d'obligation en tout
cas avec notre prestataire on va
vraiment
répondre à l'exigence de l'État après
qui dit bio dit coup supérieur donc
voilà il faut qu'on soit toujours dans
l'équilibre entre un coup supportable
pour la mairie pour les familles on a
des familles qui n'ont pas toujours les
les
finances illimitées et une exigence de
qualité le biomé aussi des circuits
courts et ça va être toute l'ambition
pour le projet Gard bécane d'améliorer
notamment les circuits courts sur les
terrains qui seront exploités par une
agriculture de proximité on a vu
malheureusement dans les derniers mois
des mers qui ont été victimes des élus
d'agressions ou de menaces est-ce que
dans l'exercice de vos fonctions vous
avez déjà eu peur physiquement la
réponse est oui je crois que le chiffre
c'est 1300 agressions sur les élus en
2019 ou 2020 et je crois que c'est
quasiment trois fois plus que l'année
vidéo précédente oui moi ça m'est arrivé
effectivement d'être confronté à des
situations moi et d'autres élus
d'hostilité de violence
ma voiture notamment s'était faite
caillasser mais je souligne globalement
malgré ces comportements assez
minoritaires quand même un respect de la
fonction un respect de la fonction du
maire et une relation qui est quand même
extraordinaire que je vis avec les
habitants relation pleine d'émotion des
mariages extrémiste que j'ai célébré à
la MGEN qui me marquera tout jamais
officielle donc c'est un mandat
extraordinaire de bonheur à partager
avec les habitants dernière question
très rapidement ce que vous êtes un
maire heureux bah la réponse est oui
heureux pourquoi parce que j'ai une
équipe qui me supporte dans tous les
sens du terme parce que j'ai des
habitants qui me font confiance
le maire c'est je dis souvent le premier
recours quand on a un problème ou quand
on a un projet et le dernier recours
quand on a un problème on est la
relation de ceux qui n'en n'ont pas et
ça donne c'est une vraie exigence et
c'est un vrai bonheur d'essayer autant
de faire ce peu d'aider concrètement les
gens qu'on a besoin et ça bien plus beau
bonheur que d'essayer d'aider les autres
merci Nicolas Dainville maire de la
commune de La Verrière très bonne année
2023 avant votre commune merci beaucoup
rendre la musique accessible à tous
voilà l'objectif de la Philharmonie de
Paris avec le dispositif des mots ce qui
on l'a dit se développera également du
côté de la commune de La Verrière dans
ce cadre une centaine d'enfants de
l'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines ont reçu leur
propre instrument de musique pour
pouvoir s'entraîner pendant 3 ans on
regarde tout de suite le reportage de
Julien Leroy et de Mathilde de Franco
[Musique]
samedi dernier une centaine d'enfants de
l'agglomération de 50 ans en Yvelines et
de Chanteloup-les-Vignes ont reçu leur
propre instruments de musique sur la
scène nationale du théâtre de Sky c'est
dans le cadre du projet demos dispositif
d'éducation musicale et orchestrale à
vocation sociale mis en place par la
Philharmonie de Paris
c'est à la fois une fierté mais aussi
une joie de voir le bonheur de ses
enfants qui vont pouvoir maintenant
rentrer dans l'apprentissage de la
musique en orchestre
parce que je sais que je continuerai à
faire du violoncelle ou
autre chanson donc bah ça me rend
heureuse alors moi je suis pressée parce
que en fait quand on m'a dit qu'on avait
reçu les instruments enfin ça m'a fait
un choc et c'était il va bien parce que
je me sentais déjà musicienne
alors ça va être cool instrument avant
accorde ou cuivre les enfants vont
suivre pendant trois ans des ateliers
hebdomadaires le tout encadré par deux
musiciens professionnels et un référent
de la structure sociale partenaire on
lutte aussi contre tous les a priori qui
consisteraient à penser que la musique
classique serait réservée à une élite et
et vraiment la spécificité de démos
c'est d'apporter la musique classique
dans les quartiers populaires et
vraiment au sein de ces quartiers dans
les structures sociales 50% des enfants
choisissent de poursuivre la musique
donc on met en place des partenariats
avec les écoles de musique locale pour
créer des passerelles et pour que les
enfants puissent intégrer les
apprentissages de des conservatoire à
l'issue de Demos nouveauté cette année
l'agglomération de 50 ans en Yvelines
devient opérateur du dispositif des
Mosses un grand concert public viendra
clôturer la saison et les enfants ont
également l'opportunité de monter sur la
grande scène de la Philharmonie de Paris
de quoi les motiver la clé de la
réussite pratique un peu tous les jours
et deux invités m'ont rejoint en plateau
Hervé forge bonsoir bonsoir président de
la pmsq c'est l'association pour la
promotion de la musique à 50 ans en
Yvelines également avec nous Gabriel
laboda bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes
directrice musicale de la maîtrise de
trappe on va parler avec vous du
prochain concert des solistes de la
ville-dieu qui sera dirigé donc par
Marianne picetti avec six jeunes
solistes c'est samedi prochain à 18h à
l'auditorium du conservatoire de musique
et de danse et de Trappes je voulais
juste vous faire réagir sur le sujet que
l'on vient de voir des mots ce qui donne
accès justement à la musique à des
jeunes et des jeunes de quartiers leur
permettre la pratique d'un instrument
qu'est-ce que vous pensez de ce type de
d'initiative et on va parler aussi de
vos missions aussi directement tout à
l'heure parce que elles sont aussi
directement liées
que c'est formidable et tous les moyens
sont bons et on leur offre un instrument
et c'est un instrument rentrer dans
l'art en touchant en jour l'instrument
c'est très bien parce que l'enfant se
rencontre avec avec du son avec avec les
collègues qui jouent ensemble enfin je
parlerai aussi l'intérêt de son courage
ça va dans le même sens
alors moi Gabriella m'a un peu convaincu
que le champ était quelque chose de
fondamental et qui était presque
d'ailleurs dans certains pays de l'Est
il est privilégié et en fait il conduit
à l'instrument donc je serais
personnellement un tout petit peu plus
réservé dans la mesure où je pense que
il est très intéressant de commencer par
le chant et ensuite de passer à
l'instrument qui en fait demande en plus
une technicité mais c'est très très bien
on va parler justement des missions de
de la pmsq mais je le disais à votre
prochain concert prochain concert des
solistes de la ville Dieu ce sera donc
samedi prochain on va peut-être voir
l'animation se réafficher à nouveau la
voilà la voici c'est donc à 18h à
l'auditorium du Conservatoire de Musique
et de Danse de Trappes avant de parler
justement des missions vous menez depuis
20 ans un mot sur sur cette
programmation au programme de romantisme
et crépuscule avec Brahms et Strauss
Hervé Farge tout à fait alors en fait si
vous voulez ce programme est très
intéressant parce qu'il est orienté sur
le pleine la pleine période du
romantisme donc avec la complicité de
Brahms et de de Strauss le romantisme en
fait a été
développé dans ce projet par
[Musique]
et en fait c'est donc la période brame
c'est la pleine période du romantisme et
donc ça va être un septuor qui va être
assez somptueux avec donc Marianne
Picchetti et si jeune soliste puisque on
a on pousse en fait les jeunes dans la
dans la progression dans la carrière
donc nos jeunes sont des gens qui sont
fin de CNSM ou en début de carrière et
on les privilégie sont les on leur donne
le pied à l'étrier si vous voulez et
ensuite alors je suis trop sales alors
je suis trop celui Richard Strauss les
métamorphoses là c'est une période très
cruelle puisque ça se passe en 1943 et
en fait c'est vraiment le un symbole de
l'horreur de ce qui s'est passé dans le
régime nazi et ça c'est en fait ça
montre un peu de le passage du
romantisme une période très très
difficile voilà avant que
et c'est d'ailleurs inspiré du
bombardement de Mun 1943 qui avait
détruit l'opéra
alors on va parler aussi de ces solistes
comment est né justement ce ces solistes
de la ville-dieu quelles sont aussi leur
mission parce qu'il y a toujours aussi
cette volonté de mêler musique classique
avec tout ce qu'elle peut avoir
d'exigence et la formation l'éducation
aussi des jeunes notamment des quartiers
tout à fait alors en fait si vous voyez
ça c'est fait quand on a démarré c'était
en 2003 on a démarré en fait ce projet
de promotion de la musique classique et
en fait de faire alors c'est une idée
très fort pour nous c'est de faire du
lien social par la musique classique la
volonté de départ c'était le lien social
c'est le lien social c'est-à-dire que en
fait on voit que les quartiers il est
difficile de d'avoir de la mixité dans
les quartiers il est difficile d'avoir
de la mixité dans les écoles et nous on
a tenu à créer une mixité alors on a eu
effectivement les solives de la ville
lieu c'est-à-dire que Marianne Piketty a
été notre conseillère artistique dès
début et on s'est dit il faut déjà
donner des concerts de très haut niveau
de très grande qualité parce qu'on s'est
rendu compte que les gens qui
connaissaient peu la musique classique
ressentait paradoxalement plus vite
quand c'était de très haut niveau ça
n'était pas et ça ça nous a vraiment
bluffé et donc elle a eu l'idée comme
elle était elle avait à l'époque les cas
une quarantaine d'années et 20 ans avant
ils étaient sortis parmi les meilleurs
des conservatoires le CNSM elle avait
des camarades qui étaient en plein boom
de leur carrière comme vous aviez
Philippe ce qui est à jouer avec
rostropovic comme
Eric Lesage qui est un immense pianiste
et se disait maintenant avec le niveau
qu'on a on aimerait bien ce serait
formidable si on faisait de la musique
de chambre puisque la musique de chambre
est très exigeante et Marie-Anne de
radis bachich mais à une condition de le
faire attrape et là ça a été l'idée de
créer en plus un nouveau public et de le
créer à Trappes et la verrière puisque
en fait on a démarré
ce qui fait que c'est un marché ça a été
d'abord effectivement ces concerts au
début ça s'appelle les solives de la
ville-dieu puisque ça a été donné dans
la chapelle de la de la commanderie des
Templiers qui à l'époque appartenait à
l'établissement public d'aménagement et
la pmsq en avait la l'usage donc on a
donné les premiers concerts là et comme
on peut traverser le pont et de l'autre
côté c'est le bois de l'étang et bien on
a invité les élèves du bois de l'étang à
traverser le pont et à venir écouter les
concerts de musique de chambre et le
premier concert a été inouï puisque
Marianne elle a eu un succès fou et les
enfants tendaient leur chaussures pour
avoir des autographes sur les chaussures
donc si vous voyez ça a été la le
premier démarrage donc les solides de la
vidéo c'est vraiment donner une image de
qualité pour ne pas dévaluer le côté
bonne
œuvre ou autre c'est au contraire une
très forte exigence de qualité et
ensuite on s'est dit notre vocation
c'est de faire de la promotion de la
musique et donc auprès de tous les
publics c'est facile de faire de la
promouvoir de la musique auprès de
mélomane mais nous on a voulu en fait
atteindre tous les toutes les
populations d'où l'idée qui avait été
initié par notre chef d'orchestre de
l'époque Pierre Michel Durand à Lille
c'est au lieu de mettre les enfants dans
la salle et puis de mettre des musiciens
sur scène c'est de mettre les enfants
sur scène et le choix ce que j'ai un peu
tout à l'heure c'est de le faire par le
chant puisque c'est des demandes des
gens qui ont peu de moyens et cette
rencontre
nous a permis si vous voulez de pousser
sur la notion du champ donc des
personnes qui rejoignent cette aventure
et Gabriela Boda en fait partie
justement ce qu'elle a rejoint
l'aventure vous l'avez rejoint en 2011
pour diriger la maîtrise de Trappes
alors je rappelle juste que vous avez
une formation classique vous êtes
d'origine hongroise votre père était
pasteur et votre mère pédiatre jouait de
l'orgue à l'église c'est comme ça que
c'est rentré dans votre vie la musique
oui de l'enfance donc ma mère jouait on
était à l'orgue à côté d'elle puis on
jouait ensemble on jouait du jazz on est
à l'école de musique à l'école on
apprend la musique pendant 8 ans
obligatoirement l'école primaire au
lycée donc c'était
c'était normal c'était naturel qu'on
chante qu'on joue donc la musique qui a
accompagné toute votre vie alors
justement quoi avec cette expérience
comment on s'adresse à des publics
jeunes des jeunes de du CP au CM2 pour
les intéresser justement la musique
comment on le fait comment vous le
faites
avec les jeux avec ce qui leur convient
pédagogiquement très structuré
mais chaque chaque étape chaque âge a
des chansons des exercices
pour leur apprendre le racine
linguistique musicaux et puis évoluer
petite personnalité aussi à travers le
champ juste peut-être voir un petit
extrait d'un concert qui a été donné
vendredi dernier à Trappes justement
avec des enfants de la maîtrise regardez
ici
[Musique]
vous souhaitiez ajouter quelque chose en
fait si vous voulez pour rebondir aussi
sur la question de comment faire
découvrir la musique pendant les
intéresser et bien ça a été cette idée
du de le des opéras des enfants en scène
c'est à dire que on a pris on a organisé
donc dès 2003 on prend une classe
entière volontaire avec l'enseignante
volontaire et toutes les semaines on les
on a une chef de chœur qui vient les
faire travailler avec des méthodes
notamment et notamment les méthodes que
Gabriel a utilisé parce qu'elle a fait
beaucoup d'interventions dans ces dans
ces écoles donc dans des méthodes très
genre un peu
Montessori sur le dans l'école elle-même
c'était faire du jeu du plaisir des
notes par des gestes des choses comme ça
et alors je vous avoue alors c'est la
méthode codaï donc tu pourras parler un
petit peu et comme c'est une classe
entière il plus ceux qui le font et ceux
qui ne font pas les enseignants du coup
sont très contents parce que ils
découvrent en même temps le champ et
petit à petit ça prend alors je vous
cache pas que la toute première année
mais là il ne faudrait des heures la
première année ça a été de la folie
parce que on a accueilli avec 400
personnes sur la scène du théâtre de 51
en Yvelines et la salle était pleine à
craquer et à la fin du spectacle on a eu
aucun applaudissement parce qu'on a eu
que des cris des tapes ont des
sifflements et tout et c'est parce que
les gens n'avaient jamais été dans une
salle de spectacle et ne savait pas
qu'on applaudissait dans une salle de
spectacle et maintenant année après
année puisque là on va fêter la 21e
édition
mais qui est étonnante parce que
maintenant vous avez un silence vous
avez comme on dit on applaudit plus
entre les mouvements etc et on a
maintenant des personnes de 20 ans qui
nous disent ah bah moi j'ai chanté sur
le thé à la terre et j'ai eu mes petits
frères mais avec beaucoup de belles
histoires on l'a compris il y a un nom
forcément qui
je dois tout de suite parler à nos à
noter les spectateurs qui quand on parle
aussi de la maîtrise de trap c'est celui
de nous gagnons de The Voice elle a été
en sixième lorsqu'elle est en 6e elle
était en 6e pardon lorsqu'elle est
entrée au sein de la maîtrise elle le
dit Gabriela ça a tout de suite match
entre vous
c'est pas avec moi c'est la musique
c'est la musique c'est la musique qui
nous rapproche qui nous unit qui nous
élève qui qui apporte tellement à ses
enfants et et il y a certains qui
découvrent une vraie vocation comme nous
qui avait envie d'aller plus loin
j'avais vu tout de suite son talent
elle chantait très bien elle chantait
elle s'implique beaucoup ça lui plaisait
beaucoup et puis derrière elle a validé
que elle voudrait continuer peut-être un
autre par une autre voie donc la voix
chantée toute seule d'autres styles la
variété et pourquoi pas et voilà
tena c'était son rêve et ben voilà
elle est restée et ça c'est bien fidèle
aussi à cette formation elle a appris le
champ elle était vendredi dernier
justement avec vous pour le concert que
vous avez donné on écoute également un
extrait un extrait de son intervention
[Musique]
première amour
je t'aime et pourtant un bout de vent
premier amour
[Musique]
est-ce que aujourd'hui encore vous lui
donnez des conseils Gabriela Boda est-ce
qu'elle vient vous voir
[Rires]
peut-être quand elle se présentait pour
le Voice Kids on a travaillé un petit
peu et voilà elle a pris ses ailes voilà
je voulais dire que nous avons été très
émus parce que elle aurait pu avoir un
peu plus comme on dit vulgairement la
grossesse alors que elle a elle a une
reconnaissance de toute la période vécue
à la avec la maîtrise et vis-à-vis de
Gabriela et elle l'a fait au moment de
ce concert et elle a même accepté de
chanter avec les enfants de la maîtrise
et je crois que c'est un très bel
exemple et c'est enfin c'était très très
émouvant ce qui est porté on l'a compris
par par la pmsq merci Hervé fort merci
Gabriela Boda je rappelle président de
la pmsq pour Hervé Farge et directrice
musicale de la maîtrise de trappe pour
Gabriel laboda et donc ce prochain
concert était soliste de la ville d'Yeu
ce sera samedi prochain à 18h à
l'auditorium de du Conservatoire de
Musique et de Danse de trappe toutes les
infos sur le site internet qui s'est
affiché dans cette animation il reste
des places Hervé forge alors il reste
des places il y a pas de problème et
puis donc ce sont de jeunes musiciens et
c'est très enthousiasmant et en plus à
la fin du concert il y a une proximité
dans cette salle donc un grand plaisir
et après on en parle avec les musiciens
avec Marianne avec les jeunes musiciens
et c'est un très très grand plaisir que
ce soit pour les mélomanes pour ceux qui
découvrent et progressent dans la
musique Gabriel et moi j'attends aussi
les enfants qui ont envie de chanter
même au milieu de on commence le nouveau
programme avec du concerts des herbes de
Don Giovanni au mois d'avril et de Gora
le grand spectacle sur la 500 donc ceux
qui ont envie de venir venez en chantant
ensemble ça fait plaisir et puis on
développe la personnalité la voix
musicalité c'est que ensemble le site
internet on le donne un www.musique
sqy.org
pour pouvoir trouver tous les contacts
et vous joindre merci encore une
nouvelle fois d'avoir été avec nous et
avant de se quitter on va jeter un
dernier coup d'oeil à la météo de demain
et de la grisaille et de la pluie au
programme de la journée de mardi le
matin il fera 6 degrés dans la moitié
nord du département 5 degrés du côté de
Rambouillet de la pluie également dans
l'après-midi côté température comptait 9
degrés à Houdan et manchent-la-jolie 8
degrés à Versailles Rambouillet ce mardi
et 10 janvier ce sera la Saint Guillaume
voilà c'est la fin de ce 7 8 merci de
votre fidélité on se retrouve dès demain
pour une nouvelle édition belle soirée
sur TV 78
[Musique]